[Music]
right welcome to one of the most
incredible soft spots anywhere in the
world nazareth now it looks pretty calm
out there but i have been out in the
ocean i've died for those incredible
pessabeth
barnacles fish for incredible sardines
let's be honest
it may be the end of summer now but in
the winter here the waves are getting up
to 30 meters literally out here crashing
over that wall into the lighthouse so
i'm going to do something a little bit
classic here in portugal bifana it's a
an amazing sandwich
that's the party boat down there going
crazy it's done with a sliced pork chop
lots of caramelized peppers onions have
a quick look at the ingredients
the pork has been marinated sliced thin
marinaded in a little bit of mastada
which is like a hot pickled fruit
alongside that some garlic olive oils
sliced nice and thinly and marinated
it's gonna be seared very quickly in
here i've got some smoked paprika okay
with some olive oil and then a beautiful
sheep's cheese we're gonna melt that
over the incredible steak lovely bread
let me get it sliced and toasted first
off start sweating off
the bloody peppers
but look at that that's how they party
in portugal down there
i mean
obviously you can smell the food put
some clothes on
how do they party like that
in the middle of the ocean start bolling
naked
seriously
you don't want to be down there you want
to be up here right first off
let's get that bread sliced and this is
going to do sort of three or four
portions
first of all
get that beautifully
cut in half
get it nicely seasoned get your smoked
paprika
and literally rub
that inside all those beautiful little
crevices
from there
i want to get that toasted
a nice season
okay i want to get that nice and crispy
that goes onto the grill
literally on and get that grilled
beautifully that's going to give it a
really nice base now top and tail your
peppers
it's a sort of rustic
delicious sandwich
that sounds like it's got beef in there
but it hasn't it's got the most amazing
pork
don't go too thin
okay go nice and thick because they take
quite a saute
leave the skin on we're going to blister
the skin and make this bifana a
delicious sandwich
onion
in half
take off the roots
and then slice again
again chilies this is got some real kick
to it this sandwich
and we use that beautiful cheese
to cool it down i'm going to show you a
technique on the barbecue it's a really
nice way
of getting the sandwich a little bit
cooler red and green chile
now
lightly seasoned
olive oil
and let's get this mixed in
[Music]
a little touch of olive oil in there
and get that
beautifully fried
sweat them off nicely
generous on the olive oil
turn that bread
they're really nice and crispy
you'll see why later
we're gonna be layering this sandwich up
okay
so get that bread nice and crispy let
them all beautifully sweat down okay
and you'll see them starting to
disintegrate
and go nice and soft
i don't want any raw flavors in there
okay so
really important to sort of
just
sweat them off
really fast
beautiful
fresh coriander
[Music]
from there
take a nice lemon
i'm gonna hit that
that beautiful citrus fill
in she goes there
and then
that acidity with the lemon juice
beautiful
take them off
[Music]
now let them sit there
for a moment the smell in there lemon
juice coriander at the end beautiful
now
get your pork
in marinade
i want to grill this beautifully
look at that
this is where the flavor comes in now
nice season
turn that off
all that really nice and crispy you'll
see why in a minute
get your pork
a little bit of the paprika oil before i
turn it
that's gonna give a really nice amount
of heat
look at the color of that oh boy
up
oh my lord beautiful
under
beautiful
beautiful
a little season
jesus
it feels like portugal's turning to
vegas a nice brush
now this important part now when we
grill that i want to cook that beautiful
smoked paprika
into that pork okay i'm going to take
some of that prosciutto
okay i wanna just get that a little bit
crispy rub a little touch of olive oil
on there
and look
see what happens to it when it goes on
the grill beautiful
so nice
beautiful
a little bit off
my god
the flavor's incredible 90 seconds each
side
get that prosciutto nice and crisp and
this is where the magic starts get your
cheese
and literally slice that down
nice and robust
i'm gonna melt that cheese
but
my prosciutto
is nice and crisp
that's going to go on top
that's done
and now will you do is get the biggest
piece on the bottom
and then from there
layer
that cheese in
another slice on top
layer that in and then literally
place it on top
take a pan place that on top
and you'll see that melt
now whilst you're waiting
pan down pan down please just justin pan
down pan down pan down
now
now justin pan down i'm pepe hello
thank you
now this is where the magic stars happen
take a little touch of mustard
spread that on
both sides
okay
oh my god the flavor get your peppers
and put them across the whole base but
be generous with those peppers okay
really generous
fill all the sides
lightly season them
look at that that's what i want to see
you see that just
i see you baby
shaking that ass
the pan on top is really important
starts to get that incredible heat in
there but most importantly starts to
melt the cheese think of the smoked
paprika the pork
the onions
that incredible pepper and the flavors
coming through are going to be amazing
oh my goodness me
and look at that the cheese has melted
up onto one quickly
the difference melting that cheese on
there is incredible
sit that on
you can now start to see
how those layers
are starting to form some fresh arugula
on top
and then my crispy
prosciutto on there
you set that on top of there
and oh boy now
[Applause]
oh man
oh boy
i mean who needs a party boat when
you've got a sandwich like that
and there she is
i mean just look at my fingers
they look slightly rude but trust me
it's cheese
wow
and there you go
a beautiful traditional beefana but look
at the back side have you ever seen a
sandwich looking that good
trust me you just want to dive in there
bona bifana
now if you enjoyed that recipe please
click the link below and if you missed
uncharted then please watch it on catch
up on disney plus
[Music]